command the Seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest free to
play combat game world of warships
download now hey guys today it is the
30th up September my name is just and
you're watching games button the
PlayStation 4 3.0 firmware update lens
today and if you haven't switched yours
on yet here's what you can expect the
250 megabyte update will let you share
videos directly to Twitter access a
dedicated PlayStation Plus section save
screenshots as pngs and create groups
the 3-pointer patch is also going to
make interface tweaks to youtube
streaming improve the messages feature
and enable you to add or create favorite
groups which you can access in your
friends apps online storage capacity has
also undergone an increase from one
gigabyte to 10 gigabytes fit here plus
numbers you can now create and join
communities around shared interest sess
communal message boards and use stickers
which for those of you who don't use
facebook Messenger are basically
elaborate emojis have fun with that one
in news that probably shouldn't surprise
you it's been announced that Assassin's
Creed syndicate will have
microtransactions just like every other
recent ubisoft game syndicate won't be
shying away from the highly
controversial decision Ubisoft Quebec
development director Francois pelland
told IGN the microtransaction model for
Assassin's Creed syndicate is quite
similar to Black Flag's allowing players
who do not have time to fully explore
our huge game worlds to still be able to
eventually acquire the game's most
powerful gear as well as other items
rest assured all of AC syndicate content
is available without paying anything
additional and the game has been
balanced such that micro transactions
are one hundred percent optional
syndicate is out on October 23 for Xbox
one and ps4 while the PC Edition will
land on November 19
and finally we have a highly
questionable marketing choice the
official call of GD Twitter accounts
tweeted out a fake terrorist attack to
promote their game Activision posted a
series of tweets about a supposed
explosion in Marina Bay Singapore
account reported that the source of the
explosion was at coalescence
corporations a fictional company
featured in a teaser for black ops 3 the
account then announced the country
within a state of emergency and declared
martial law before rounding out with
this was a glimpse into the future
fiction of hashtag black ops 3 the
tweets confirmed a character named James
Chung will be tied into the game as
commander of the Singapore Armed Forces
and the second account called the
unmarked man replied with conspiracy
theory speculations as you'd expect a
bunch of people thought the fake news
was in extremely poor taste particularly
as the Twitter verified account with
over 2.8 million followers had altered
its picture name and details to appear
as a real world news outlet leave me
your opinion on the call of duty
marketing campaign down in that comment
but you can also have the game spot
where we've got news on the last of us
too and a lego Xbox one bundle that is
everything you're happy today as always
let me know what you cared about and I
will catch you same time tomorrow
you